vous êtes-vous déjà demandé s'il
existait une planète semblable à la
Terre ailleurs dans l'univers
et comment on s'y prendrait pour la
découvrir
d'ailleurs à quel point le cette planète
différée de la terre tout en étant
semblable à elle
qu'est-ce qui fait que la terre et la
terre finalement et pas Vénus qui lui
ressemble tellement
si cette planète existait semblable à la
Terre serait-elle habitable ou non
habitable
alors je suis astrophysicienne ou
astronome et ces questions sont au cœur
de mon travail
depuis
30 ans on connaît des planètes
extrasolaires et on les appelle aussi
exoplanètes ce sont juste les planètes
qui tournent autour d'autres étoiles que
le Soleil
alors depuis 30 ans effectivement on a
fait énormément d'innovations sur nos
instruments et nos méthodes de mesures
et on en connaît aujourd'hui énormément
je vais essayer de vous partager ça un
peu aujourd'hui alors partons de notre
système solaire celui qu'on connaît
mieux ou la planète la plus facile à
voir si on était un astronome
extraterrestre serait Jupiter Jupiter et
mille fois plus volumineuse que la terre
elle est donc plus facile à trouver
malgré tout si on était sur une autre
étoile et qu'on regardait notre Soleil
est-ce qu'on verrait Jupiter et bien on
verrait le soleil essentiellement le
problème est dans le contraste de
lumière Jupiter malgré sa taille est un
milliard de fois moins lumineuse que le
soleil donc depuis l'extérieur on ne
verrait que le soleil est pas du tout
Jupiter ni les autres planètes
évidemment
du coup on a inventé des nouvelles
méthodes des méthodes indirectes qui
consiste à regarder l'étoile qui est si
brillante et chercher des des façons
indirecte de découvrir les planètes qui
sont autour je vais vous parler de deux
de ces méthodes la première consiste à
chercher l'ombre portée par la planète
sur le disque de l'étoile pendant
qu'elle passe devant c'est facile pour
une planète comme Jupiter qui grosse
c'est 100 fois plus difficile pour une
planète comme la terre qui passe qui
prend une toute petite partie de la
lumière du soleil imaginez si vous êtes
toujours cet astronome extraterrestre et
que vous regardez le soleil vous allez
voir une fois par an passer la planète
Terre pendant 12 heures devant le disque
du soleil elle prendra une minuscule
partie de son de sa lumière donc
difficile mais faisable
une autre méthode indirecte consiste à
mesurer le déplacement de l'étoile dû à
la présence de la planète comme la
planète tourne autour avec une grande
vitesse elle implique une petite
déplacement de l'étoile qu'on peut
regarder avec nos instruments terrestres
alors il y a 30 ans quand ses premières
mesures ont été faites on a pu découvrir
des planètes de cette façon là avec en
mesurant la vitesse des étoiles de
l'ordre de la vitesse d'un avion
20 ans plus tard on savait déjà faire
100 fois mieux mesurer des vitesses de
l'étoile qui était de l'ordre d'un
piéton qui marche lentement donc on
avance très très vite dans ces méthodes
là
mais il nous reste encore un facteur 10
à gagner en performance de ces
instruments pour être capable de mesurer
le mouvement que ce qui impliquerait la
terre sur le sur le soleil
donc ce facteur 10 un petit peu
difficile encore imaginez maintenant que
pour une même planète on soit capable de
d'utiliser ces deux méthodes les
ombres et le déplacement on serait alors
capable de mesurer la densité de ces
planètes sans les avoir vu une seule
fois on se récap donc capable de savoir
si une planète est plutôt gazeuse plutôt
rocheuse ou encore autre chose alors je
vais tout de suite vous enlever le
suspense on a découvert des milliers
d'exoplanètes on est capable pour des
milliers d'exoplanètes de savoir quel
est leur densité et de savoir si elles
sont gazeuses ou rocheuses et on a
découvert une diversité énorme on a
découvert des planètes géantes comme
celle du système solaire à peu près
comme Jupiter Saturne ou Uranus et puis
on a découvert d'autres planètes géantes
qui n'ont rien à voir avec celle du
système solaire qui sont soit beaucoup
plus vaporeuses soit beaucoup plus dense
et on a découvert plus petit dans le
plus petit gabarit de planète on a
découvert des superters donc des
planètes plus grosses que la terre et
qui sont quand même rocheuses et puis
des planètes intermédiaires qui ne sont
ni rocheuses ni gazeuses et qui donc ont
la potentialité d'être liquide ou d'être
recouverte d'un énorme océan d'eau
alors d'où vient cette diversité en fait
la diversité des planètes vient de la
diversité des étoiles les étoiles sont
toutes différentes il y en a des grosses
des petites des choses et des froides il
y en a qui ont un champ magnétique
énorme mais il y en a qui sont riches en
éléments lourds et d'autres moins et
donc toute cette diversité des étoiles
va faire que le disque de poussière dans
lequel se forme ces planètes va être
très différent d'une étoile à l'autre et
c'est ça qui va arriver à la faire des
planètes ou des cortèges de planètes
très différents les uns des autres
c'est en regardant la diversité des
étoiles qui nous environnent dans la
galaxie 100 milliards d'étoiles dans la
galaxie qu'on est capable de remonter
aux étapes de formation qui ont été
celles du système solaire et a donc
comprendre notre environnement terrestre
alors où en sommes-nous de
la de cette connaissance on sait qu'il y
a donc plus de 100 milliards d'étoiles
dans notre galaxie si on regarde juste
notre petite banlieue les quelques 400
étoiles qui sont à moins de 30
années-lumière par exemple on connaît
déjà plusieurs planètes plusieurs
dizaines de planètes dans ce dans cette
petite bulle et je vais m'arrêter sur
l'une d'entre elles qui est proxima
proxima c'est l'étoile la plus proche du
Soleil Proxima du Centaure elle est une
toute petite étoile
au centre de ce carré ici et cette
petite étoile on a découvert en 2016 sa
première planète on sait maintenant
qu'il y en a sans doute deux peut-être
plus encore
alors je reviendrai plus tard sur cette
planète de proxima je vous ai juste dire
que proxima est une étoile un peu
particulière n'a pas grand chose à voir
avec le soleil elle est beaucoup plus
petite elle est dix fois plus petite que
le soleil c'est pour ça qu'elle est si
faible et savoir un impact sur sa
planète comme vous le verrez plus tard
alors je voudrais maintenant venir à une
notion importante pour nous à la fois
pour la recherche des exoplanètes et
l'étude de ces de ces mondes différents
et puis qui a en même temps un écho pour
notre vie sur Terre l'habitabilité
qu'est-ce qui fait qu'une planète est
habitable ou ne l'est pas qu'est-ce qui
fait que la terre est habitable et
jusqu'à le point jusqu'à quel point
est-elle habitable qu'est-ce qu'il va
faire à distance qu'on sera capable de
découvrir l'habitabilité de ces planètes
alors on a commencé par des premiers
critères d'abord on pense qu'il faut une
surface rocheuse pour une planète
habitable ensuite il y a une certaine
zone autour de chaque étoile qui va
permettre une température à la surface
de cette planète qui permettra
l'existence d'eau liquides on appelle ça
la zone habitable si la planète était
plus proche de l'étoile l'océan le
liquide à la surface s'évaporait si la
planète à l'inverse était plus loin de
l'étoile le liquide se gèlerait dans le
sol donc il y a vraiment une distance
parfaite
et je vous rassure tout de suite la
terre est dans la zone habitable du
soleil il y a donc cette distance
parfaite à chaque étoile propre à chaque
étoile ou
la surface de la planète peut être
couverte d'eau on appelle ça la zone
habitable
est-ce que c'est si simple que ça malgré
tout on a un petit peu des idées avec
les problèmes climatiques sur terre que
l'importance de l'atmosphère par exemple
est assez importante assez grande donc
est-ce que ces planètes aussi auraient
une atmosphère on sait sur terre
l'importance qui a eu la lune dans
l'histoire dynamique de la terre est-ce
que ces planètes ont des lunes
on sait aussi l'importance qui a eu
Jupiter dans le système solaire en
déviant les astéroïdes qui pourraient
s'écraser sur la terre
donc tout ça cet environnement beaucoup
plus complexe des planètes tout ça on ne
le connaît pas pour les exoplanètes donc
c'est un premier pas cette zone
habitable et la présence de planètes
rocheuses mais on sent bien que c'est
beaucoup plus compliqué que ça pour
donner un exemple sur une des planètes
exotiques sur lesquelles on a été
capable de chercher la composition de
l'atmosphère on a découvert qu'il y
avait probablement des orages de fer sur
cette planète donc des grandes pluies la
condensation du fer qui qui se passe
dans l'atmosphère et qui tombe sur le
sur la surface
il y a malgré tout 60 planètes
dans la zone habitable de leur étoile et
qui sont rocheuses donc on a quand même
un premier catalogue de planètes
intéressantes à regarder
alors je reviens sur proxima donc
proxima je vous ai dit une toute petite
étoile et sa planète à 11 jours de
période orbitale la durée de son année
et de 11 jours ça veut dire que sa
distance à l'étoile est toute petite
seulement 5% de la distance entre la
Terre et le Soleil à cette distance-là
on sait que la planète subit beaucoup de
choses de l'étoile en premier lieu un
vent de particules énergétique très
violent bon alors on espère que cette
planète a un champ magnétique pour s'en
protéger
autre chose un effet de marée un très
important dû à l'étoile qui va obliger
la planète à montrer toujours sa même
face à l'étoile cette planète a donc un
côté jour et un côté nuit un gradient de
température entre le côté jour et le
côté nuit qui doit être assez grand
surtout s'il n'y a pas d'atmosphère et
des vents entre les deux qui va être
aussi qui vont être aussi très
éprouvants
alors voilà vous auriez espéré que je
vous dise que la l'étoile la plus proche
a une planète habitable c'est pas tout à
fait la situation qu'on connaît mais on
peut avoir des surprises et il faut
surtout garder l'esprit ouvert dans ces
histoires là
alors où en sommes-nous aujourd'hui il y
a ces planètes qu'on commence à
connaître est-ce qu'on connaît une
planète semblable à la Terre pas
vraiment on connaît des planètes qui
sont aussi grosses aussi massives que la
terre on connaît des planètes qui ont la
même distance à leur étoile que la Terre
du Soleil on connaît des planètes qui
ont la même température de surface du
Soleil que la Terre mais on ne connaît
pas une planète qui est toutes ses
propriétés à la fois et qui vous soient
donc semblables à la Terre
il manque ce facteur 10 en particulier
pour mesurer la masse d'une planète
semblable à la Terre qu'on n'a pas
encore
atteint avec nos instruments de mesure
quand on aura fait cette ce pas
supplémentaire dans la technologie des
qu'on utilise pour mesurer la masse des
planètes on sera alors gêné par la
surface de ces étoiles les étoiles
autour desquelles tournent les planètes
ne sont pas des boules toutes lisses
elles ont une surface bouillonnante qui
va faire que
qui va gêner en fait notre mesure de la
du déplacement de l'étoile et du coup
il est vraiment important en même temps
qu'on développe les instruments les
méthodes de mesure etc qu'on développe
aussi les notre connaissance la
recherche fondamentale sur les processus
physiques et la nature des de ces objets
que sont les planètes et les étoiles les
objets plutôt complexes
alors il faut rester créative et créatif
dans ce domaine de recherche pour aller
de l'avant et continuer à faire à la
fois innover nos instruments de mesure
et
grandir la connaissance sur nos modèles
théoriques des planètes et des étoiles
c'est en s'intéressant à ses objets là
qu'on comprend aussi l'importance de
notre vie sur Terre est-ce que la terre
est finalement une planète spéciale ou
une planète banale
est-ce que on va trouver une diversité
aussi importante des planètes quand on
en sera à découvrir les catalogues enfin
les planètes semblables à la Terre parce
que dans quelques années on ne peut pas
douter que on aura un catalogue de
planètes semblables à la Terre qui
seront des planètes rocheuses tempérées
et tout à fait agréable à vivre
maintenant il ne restera plus qu'une
chose à faire c'est de d'aller chercher
des traces du vivant sur ces planètes
j'aimerais ajouter que à la comme un
reflet de la diversité des planètes
qu'on a découvertes dans ces mondes
extraterrestres il faudrait que ces
recherches soient basées sur la
diversité des humains et que tout le
monde participe à ses recherches là
donc vous l'aurez compris l'innovation
pour moi à ses racines dans la recherche
fondamentale et dans la société et sa
diversité et donc il faut juste garder
l'esprit ouvert et continuer à se poser
des questions je vous remercie